As we're online today, you can't raise
your hands, but just nod at your screen.
How many of you have spent a significant
part of your career
making making software move from one
computer to another?
CI pipelines, packagers, registries,
container images, app store reviews.
That entire stack exists to solve
exactly one problem.
Get a frozen artifact, that code,
from machine where it was built to the
machine where it runs, safely,
reproducibly, once.
And here's what I think everyone is
missing.
That entire stack is built around one
idea that is so old that is so old that
we stopped seeing it as a choice.
One version of your software for
everyone.
We've shipped it that way for so long
that almost nobody asks why anymore.
I'm Iris. I'm one of the co-founders of
Differ.
My co-founder Noam was the first
engineer at JFrog. He helped build the
pipeline that I'm about to tell you is
dying.
I came at it from the other end.
I spent a decade in fintech. I was early
at a digital bank that we scaled and
exited.
Shipping software in the environments
least willing to tolerate what I'm about
to propose. So, I totally get any
reservations and I've had them myself as
well.
However, I'm telling you it's coming
anyway. And
that's not a warning. It's the best
thing that's happened to software in a
long time.
Every piece of distribution
infrastructure that you've touched
encodes the same assumption.
Software is produced in one place.
It runs in another.
Anything in the middle, the artifact, is
frozen.
And that assumption was correct. For
decades, it was just true.
Why?
Because producing a correct change was
expensive.
It took skilled humans hours or days.
So, you did it rarely. It was a central
event. You verified it and froze it.
And you shipped that frozen thing to
everyone.
So, the one-way pipeline is not
arbitrary.
It's the direct consequence
of production of software being
expensive and risky.
And
of course, the frozen artifact has some
advantages. You get
reproducibility, previewability,
rollback.
And every guarantee that we lean on in
production flows from one fact.
There is one artifact and it doesn't
change after we ship it.
That's the deal. One version for
everyone, frozen.
We call it reliability.
But the price was that the software
couldn't really be for anyone in
particular.
And nobody ever made that decision.
There was never a meeting where someone
put one version for everyone versus a
version for each person and picked the
first one.
And it wasn't because the second option
if a version for each person was worse.
It just wasn't an option.
Giving to users different software meant
forking the code base and hand
maintaining both.
A version per user at any real scale
wasn't really a viable option.
And one version for everyone never had
to win an argument. It was just how it
was. It was the only shape software
could take.
And we started treating it as a fact
about software like gravity, like
something that that is just true.
But it was never really a fact about
software. It was a fact about cost and
budget and the economics and that cost
just changed. Now, you might you might
expect me to go into AI 10 code, but
everyone has already said it and that's
stable stakes and to me that's not
really the interesting part. The
interesting part is where and how cheap
The cost of producing a correct and
scope change
is collapsing towards zero and
just as importantly
the production of the software no longer
has to happen in one place up front
before anyone runs it.
Part of it can be run on the server,
part of it on the client, part in the
user's live session.
And as each step stops being a decision
you freeze at build time
and
and now starts becoming more of a
real-time one
that also means that
each each each piece can be placed
wherever it makes most sense including
right in front of the user in their
context.
And so this whole one-way pipeline
existed because making software was the
expensive, central, and rare event and
running it was cheap.
So you separated development from
distribution.
But now as making a change becomes as
cheap as running one and it can happen
in the same place
as um
as where you run it, the reason to
separate them
is dissolving. So far I've talked about
the supply side.
Producing code has become cheap
easy. We can now make a change on a per
user basis.
But I also want to address the demand
side.
People have always wanted software that
fits them and we have decades of proof
for that.
It just wasn't really possible for most
types of software because of cost.
To start with one example, the forward
deployed engineer.
Enterprise software has always had a
line item called professional services
and a whole industry exists around that.
If you are a big client of a company
like Salesforce, you probably have
consultants that are helping you
implement
custom setups, configurations.
You have an engineer living in your
Slack channel, and it's not that
smaller customers
can't benefit from this type of
customization.
It just didn't make sense financially
until today.
To give another example that might
resonate with
you as engineers,
think about your dot files, your editor
config, key bindings.
You rebuild every tool you touch into
your tool by hand on every machine.
It's another example of a demand for
personalized software.
And lastly, Excel, the most successful
business software ever created. And
Excel isn't really
a
static program.
It's millions of people that all build
their own programs on top of it.
So, that's where. Give people the power
to make software to make their software
theirs, and they take it. Seen in the
social feed that per user wins on wins
from one size fits all on every metric
that mattered.
This is more of an example of content
versus software.
But now that we have
uh better coding again now we have
coding agents and better coding agents,
we can move this also to the software
layer. So, my point is none of this is
really new demand. We've seen it for
decades. There have been predecessors
like feature flags, segmentation, AB
testing. There's an enormous industry
around uh uh around this, and
we've been trying to make software
diverge for many years.
But
we go forced into a specific shape, that
of creating buckets and segments that
you declare in advance.
And
now, for the first time, we can make
software truly adaptive.
So, to get back to the title of this
talk, when the agent is the runtime,
when the thing that runs your software
can also modify it,
development and distribution stop being
two phases.
The boundary blurs and it's gone.
And the shape that we bet on at Differ
is that instead of one code base gated
by flags and shipped to everyone,
you deploy
one canonical stem
and every user runs her own divergence
of it.
Same origin,
but individually adapted live.
It's going from the least first version
for everyone
to the best version for anyone.
Now, if you're any of such a person, you
might be a little worried. Your stomach
might be turning because
I have just deleted the frozen artifact
and the frozen artifact was what was
holding up the entire
the the entire building. And I do we do
get these objections, for example, from
a call that I had with a CTO recently
who is right to be skeptical. What he
said roughly was,
"I can already barely reason about one
AI-generated code base.
And you want me to run millions of
these? You're not describing a
capability. You're describing my worst
problem multiplied."
And if that's your reaction, that's not
surprising. It's the right instinct, but
perhaps aimed at the wrong target.
Here's the distinction that we make. The
brittleness that you're picturing is a
specific type of failure mode. It's
unmanaged divergence inside a single
artifact.
Thousand-line files, everything can
touch everything else, no boundaries.
And
that's not not that's not necessarily
brittle because it's AI-generated. It's
brittle because there's no structure
separating things.
In our In our vision, we've we're
thinking about per-user divergences. And
don't write that is the opposite of
that. You've got a stem plus
divergences. The divergences are
bounded, isolated, and individually
reversible.
A bad variant can silently corrupt the
stem or reach another user.
Which means that the blast radius
of a changes in the system is one
context. And
any single divergence can roll back life
with no deploy. So, the answer to the
previous objection isn't trust us, AI is
good at coordination or coding.
The
honest answer is you're brittle because
there's a tangled artifact with no
boundaries.
In our case, we don't ship you a
thousand single artifacts. We ship one
stem and bounded divergences. Each
isolated, each reversible.
The thing that you're afraid of is the
thing that this architecture exists to
prevent.
And as a developer, you can also set
controls and boundaries. What can and
cannot be adapted. To give a small
example, um we can have a scenario where
we've got a form and the form can be
adapted in order to
improve conversion rate, for example.
However, as a developer, you can always
indicate that specific fields can never
be dropped or
parts of your app, like off or payments,
should always be out of um
uh uh
should always be off limits for any sort
of adaptation.
So, give another example to make
adaptive software a bit more concrete.
Uh think of, for example, um a CRM.
In this case, uh we've got an investor
who's using a CRM. Whereas, the CRM was
mostly built with a salesperson in mind.
And as an investor,
you might use it slightly differently.
So, this investor, she
often logs founder intros, and she's
always logging who intro'd her to which
deal.
So, the system observes that and creates
a
um create creates a
intro path.
The system can also observe that she's
always skipping specific fields. She
never fills them out. So, over time, the
system learns
and
doesn't surface those fields, but
instead it surfaces fields that she that
she cares about more.
Another example can be the fact that she
is always um always checking specific
types of deals or founders, and it
doesn't exactly follow
the prioritization that the system sets
by default. So, again, can can we learn
and make that smarter so that the
information that the user cares about is
surfaced first.
Not only can a system observe, but there
is also that the user can proactively
request changes, and as long as these
changes are within
the boundaries that the developer sets,
and as long as they are within the
spirit of the software, within the
purpose of what the software was
originally made for,
it can be implemented without having to
go back to the developer.
So, you can imagine for
a for a horizontal SaaS like a CRM,
you can address
a much wider number of customer personas
without increasing your R&D spend.
Now, of course, there is there are many
hard parts when it comes to bringing
this to life.
And I'm going to discuss a couple of
hard challenges and problem and problems
that we're uh that we're working on as
we're making adaptive software real at
scale.
We haven't solved all of them, but we
have a we have a point of view on each
of them, and it's that it's exactly what
we're working on day in, day out.
So, what changes when there's no single
artifact?
Firstly,
the source of truth.
So, what when there's no single
artifact, you can wonder what is the
software?
In our case, we consider the software to
be the stem plus the plus all the mutual
immutable divergences.
But of course, that creates a lineage
problem.
What is this user running and why?
That now becomes more of a graph query
versus a version number.
A bug report describes a program that
exists
for that specific user.
How do you debug or
inspect that? The answer is every
divergence is immutable, inspectable,
attributable.
And
we also need to trace any version back
to
the signal that to this specific
recommendation and this exact
adaptation.
That's one of the parts that we're
working on.
Second is correctness. Like how do you
test that's the um how do you test that
the code change that you've just
implemented
works, that UI is correct,
and yeah, testing at
a much larger scale of users means that
you need to reason about the stem and
also every possible divergence of it.
And then there's desirability because
perhaps you made a code change, it's
perfectly correct and working,
but you also need to know that whether
whether this was desirable.
Was it actually a good change?
Because anyone can
make a code change now, but the hard
part is knowing whether you actually
found
an improvement, an uplift.
And yeah, that that is something that is
extremely important to to keep track of
and to measure and to consider what the
goals for the company are. And this is
not going to be the same for every
single piece of software. In some cases,
it might be retention or less churn
or lowering the number of support
tickets.
So, it's extremely important to keep
track of
what are what are the goals that we're
chasing with adaptive software and
do the adaptations
reach to
improve improve improve the metrics that
matter.
Next is autonomy versus control. And
the conservative answer here would be
start with just recommendations and
don't make any autonomous changes. And
that's not a wrong strategy,
but in our case, it's not really our
vision. The vision is a system that
understands the user well enough to act
without asking the developer for
permission every time first.
So, for us, the challenge isn't building
more control.
It's winning enough trust that you don't
have to. And it's a hard problem, but
also
also very interesting one. And you know,
how do you make a system
good enough,
legible enough, reliable enough that
humans in the loop choose to
step back.
And
that's certainly what we are building
towards.
And lastly, coordination. Everyone on
their own version, how do you
push new updates? How do how do changes
propagate
to like a million different versions?
And this is one of the
challenges that we've been thinking
hardest about.
Yeah, and the answer that we keep coming
back to is
don't merge code, merge intent, merge
outcome. Which means not everyone has to
run the same commit or this exact same
piece of code, but everyone converges on
the same goal through their own path.
And if it wasn't already clear, the
challenges that I just
addressed are the hard challenges.
Generation has become easy, and I would
say that's actually the easy 80%.
Calling a model to
write some code is something that
everyone can do.
The other part, observability,
validation, coordination, that is the
entire business.
Anyone can call an LM, but the substrate
is stem plus diver plus divergences,
provenance, validation,
that is really the hard part, and
something that we're working on every
single day.
To close off with, when I started out in
fintech, a bank with no branches sounded
reckless.
A decade later,
the the branch is the weird part.
My co-founder, Noam, used to fight with
engineers about why you need builds and
CI.
We've seen this We've seen these shifts
before, and adaptive software is the
same type of shift.
It doesn't feel obvious
until it does.
To go back to the start of the talk, the
pipeline didn't fail because it didn't
work anymore, but
the constraint it was built for went
away.
The assumption underlying of that
software is expensive, so we need to
freeze it and ship it once.
That assumption stopped being true.
And when making software get as cheap as
running it,
the line between distribution and
development isn't a line anymore.
We spent 20 years getting good at
shipping one version for everyone.
The next 20 years are about shipping the
right version to anyone
with the isolation and provenance that
makes it safe instead of terrifying.
I'm Iris, this is different and that's
what we're building. Thank you for
watching.